wall e
me
uh
wh
この姿を見てどう思いますか
なんかお腹についてますよね
これ妊婦体験 the ケットっています
10キロぐらいのただのお守りなんですけどこうやって付けることで
臨月の妊婦さんのお腹の重さを体験できるんです
皆さんにさんってどんなイメージがありますか
僕は大変そうだなあっていうのとすごいなっていうのが半分半分くらいです
体の変化に伴ってつわりがある人もいたりします
イライラしたり不安になったりもします
出産時の痛みってとんでもないらしいですし押し星としている女性はそれを休まなきゃ
いけなかったりします
妊婦さんの大変さってお腹が重くなることだけではもちろんないですけどでもその一つ
だけでも体験できたらよくないですか
日本ではこれ保健所などに置いてあって
両親学級だったり中学高校の授業などで使われているんです
僕実はこの入部体験ジャケットと一緒に世界周してきました
1年3カ月をかけて43カ国巡ってきたんです
その中で合計1070人の人にこの妊婦体験してもらってきたんです
目指していたのはズバリ
お母さんに優しい世界を作ること
このための僕なりのアプローチが良いパパを増やすことでした
今日僕は皆さんと一緒に旅をしたいです
どうしてこんなことを思い立ったのか
どんなふうにして2分体験してもらってきたのか
どんな人たちと出会って旅の最後に何を思ったのか
15分でせ回収するので頑張ってついてきてください
はいではまず僕の
小さかった頃の話からさせてください
もうそのちっちゃい頃から僕たりが好きでした
相棒のママチャリと一緒にいろんなとこ行ったりしてて
そんななんか中学2年生の時です
自転車で世界周した方の講演会を聞きました
わくわくするような語り口だったり鮮やかな写真に心奪われて
いつか僕も世界すしたいとか海外で働きたいって夢見るようになったんです
で高校3年生になったとき進路を決めるぞってなった時でした
ん
海外で働てしかも目の前の人の力になれるようなそんな仕事って何だろうって考えまし
た
うーんと悩みに悩んだ末僕が出した答えはお医者さんになることでした
無事北大の医学部に入学した後その夢に近づくためさまざまな学生団体に参加したりし
ました
その中で5証券というものに興味を持っていきます
皆さんぼ証券って言葉をご存知でしょうか
女性が妊娠してお腹が大きくなって赤ちゃんが生まれてその赤ちゃんが大きくなって
いく
この一連のことを支援する医療や保健サービスのことを指します
僕がそれに興味は持った理由は大きく二つ一つ目が
国際協力の中でも特に困ってるんじゃないかなって思ったこと2つ目が僕の母の存在
です
1つ目の理由を説明するためにこれから3つの数字を出したいと思います
23分死亡率と呼ばれる
お山でおかあさんがなくなってしまうしね割合を示したものです
ちょっと考えてもらいたいんですけど日本では何回に1回の割合でお母さんがお産で
なくなっちゃうと思いますか
世界でもトップレベルでいいんです
正解は
2万回に1回でした
日本語に万が一って言葉あるじゃないですか2万分の1なので日本では漫画0.5にお
山でおかあさんを知らないって覚えておいてください
では今度西アフリカのシエラレオネっていう国ここが世界でワーストになってしまっ
てるんですけどどれぐらいだと思いますか
はい
じゃあこんな感じだったんですよとにかくこの3つの数字から言いたかったことなん
ですけど
まず日本の3回ではけっこうすごいということ
ただそれと同じくらいのことが実現できている国っていうのはほんの一部だけ世界全体
で見たら
をさんはまだまだ命が気になっています
でも日本のことからわかるとおり適切な医療介入があったらずいぶんたくさんの
お母さんは知らなくていいんです
まあ
こんな風に
僕が考えたのは
まだまだ改善の余地があって働きがいがあるんじゃないかって思ったことそれが一つ目
の理由でした
二つ目の理由は僕のお母さんのことです
自分が小学校低学年くらいの時に葉身は離婚していてそれ以降
母が自分を含めた3兄弟育て上げてくれました
葉は高校の英語の先生してるんですけど教育に芯があるところとか
先生として頑張っているところとても尊敬していて
もちろんそんな面と向かって母にこんなことは真面目残していないんですけどでも
世界のお母さんとかベイビーたちの力になれる仕事がいいなって思うのは
まずその自分の母を尊敬してるっていう所が一つあります
そんな風にぼ証券に興味を持つようになったのと並行して
自分の
学生生活のうちに世界史したいっていう思いが膨らんできました
大学1年生の終わりには
3年後休学をして旅に出ようっていう決意を固めて
休学した休学の手続きをしたりバイトをしたりしている中であっという間に月日は流れ
てきました
ん
そして出発3ヶ月前になったときです
とりあえず旅に出れたらいいなーって思ってたんですけど
なんかそこでふと思ったんです
今の時代世界一周ってなんだかんだありふれてる自分だけしかできないことってなんか
ないかなーって思ったんです
じゃあ何がいいかなーとか色々考えてる時にあるときポッと思いつきました
ん
妊婦体験ジャケットと一緒に旅したらいいんじゃないかって言っ
これあの簿証券のことで僕の興味のあることだったんです
だからいいのかなって
もう思いついたら無我夢中で準備をしました
そして2015年2月19日僕は
たびに入れました
では今度実際にどんな旅をしたかなんですけど
世界地図で説明していきたいとおもいます青色がいくろ
黄色が空路飛行機で飛んだところです
順番に
アジア
中途
ヨーロッパ
アフリカ
南米
中米
北米っていう順番に
43カ国旅してたんです
だいたい資金は180万円くらいかかったんですけど1年3カ月でそのうちの5分の1
くらいの40万円はクラウドファンディングというサービスを利用して支援してもらっ
ていました
では今度世界一周のことじゃなくて妊婦体験の
このどうやって当ててもらったかって話なんですけど
まあ試行錯誤の連続だったんですこれたぶん誰もやったことがなかったのだろうと思う
んですけど
もちろんググっても出てこないんですよねやり方なんて
最初のに訪れた国を中国では慣れてなかったのか大事にやってもらえなかったですね
少しずつ自分なりのやり方を見つけていきましたん
まず最初にこんな感じで説明の紙を書いたんです
その国の言葉で
説明としてまず一番上自己紹介
真ん中には妊婦体験の紹介
一番下には良いパパになってねっていうメッセージが書いてあります
で絵とかも書いて見てすぐ分かるようにしてました
で今度人パイ県ジャケットの準備なんですけど
普段はこんな感じでぺっちゃんこです
使うときだけ水を10キロ分野て重くして使ってました
なんかよく勘違いされちゃうんですけど僕これずっと重くしてはくってわけじゃなくて
だいたい3日にいっぺんぐらいですそれ以外の日は観光したり
移動したり旅を純粋に楽しんでました
このを守りこれずっと1年で付けてるってなったら
新録体も
途中で発狂してたかもしれないですだから楽しながらやってたってことを覚えていって
くださいそんな感じですべての準備が整ったらこういう感じに自分に妊婦体験
ジャケットをつけて街をてくてく歩いてきます
であなんかあそこに話し聞いてくれそうなお兄さんがいるぞってなったらまずは元気
よく挨拶をして声をかけます
いきなり妊婦体験の話をすると結構びっくりされちゃうので
まずは世間話をしたりして相手との心の距離を縮める努力をしていました
妄想空いいかなぁというところでその説明の紙をピって出して日台気しませんかって
聞いたんです
で大体のお兄さんが絞りますごめんちょっと恥ずかしいとか
時間がないからそこをやってをやってようっていう感じで
高
聞いてみるんです
そんな感じでしているとだいたい3人に1人くらいは ok くれました
ok くれたらこんな感じで
つけてもらって妊婦体験スタートです
主に3つのことをお願いしてました一つ目が歩いたり階段を上り下りしてもらう
二つ目が床にある物を拾ってもらう
三つ目が横になってもらう
他にも
掃除をしてもらったりとか
頭の上に物を乗せてもらったりとかこんな
現地の妊婦さんたちが実際にしている動作をしてもらってお腹に思いがあることでどう
違うのかっていうのを感じてもらってました
一連の体験が全部終わったら
的野めめのメッセージを毎回同じ内容で伝えてました
英語だとこんな感じです
face takobo ベイビースロー梅園では mother 3 step b
apu グッドファーザー
日本語だとあなたの赤ちゃんや奥さんお母さんを大切にしてください
除染を尊重しているパパになってくださいねみたいな感じです
僕はこの言葉を相手の目をまっすぐ見て心を込めて言うようにしていました
時々目を潤ませてしっかり観返してくれる人がいたんです
僕はそんな時に
この活動してて良かったなーって思えたんです
鳥はいろんなことがありました
カンボジアで出会ったこの23最初はよそよそしい感じだったんですけど
徐々に徐々に心を開いてくれて奥さんのこととかこれから生まれてくる赤ちゃんのこと
話してくれました
なんかミャンマーで気付いたり新聞に載ってたんですよ
なんかなんていうんですよね宿の人がたまたま見つけてくれて教えてくれたんですね
これお前じゃんみたいな
はい
なぁまぁビックリしましたまあ
買いに行きましたすぐこれ
中東のイランという国であったこの2人のことが僕は忘れられません
彼氏さんが妊婦体験してくれたんですけどそれを見てくれた彼女さんがこう言ってくれ
たんです
本当にステキだしこんな日本人の平和な考え方が私たちは大好きなんですよって
僕はそれがとっても嬉しくて
辛い時とかによく思い出してました
afuri カーでは
マンネリ感に苦しんでました
妊婦体験を世界の男性たちにしてもらうっていう日常に自分自身が新鮮さを感じられ
なくなってたんです
そんな中ザンビアという国の農村部の子のご家庭にホームステイさせてもらってたん
ですけど
何ですかね一緒にのんびり暮らしている中で
そこにそのままあるものがいいなーって思えるようになったんです
なんか同じ形式なんてひとつもないし同じ人なんてどこにもいないですよね
でもそんな当たり前の事も僕はわかんなくなっちゃったりしてました
ん
これは
南米のチリで出会った2人なんですけどこんな風に即興で出産のデモンストレーション
してくれたりしたんですよね
この味も迫真の演技でした
そういう南米のラテンのノリっていうのが僕大好きだったんです
コロンビアで出会った子の方がちょうど1000人目の妊婦体験してくれた人でした
ん
僕ずっとその仙人ての目標にしてたんですよ
だからもう本当に本当にこの時嬉しくてみんなとバイバイして
そう一人になった後は駐車場の隅の方でボロンボロンボロンないっちゃいましたね
はい
そんな風に
泣き笑いを繰り返して日本に帰ってきました
僕は
世界一周に出発する前
世界変えられるって思ってました
でも妊婦体験の活動うまくいかないことばっかりでした
一日中歩き回って声をかけてもらっても誰にも相手にしてもらえなかった日がありまし
た
面と向かってこんな活動意味ないよって言われたこともあります
バカにされたり花で我々たりして
それが
悔しくて寂しかったです
世界はあまりにも大きくて自分は小さい
僕には世界は変えられない
北大での学生生活に戻ってからはより一層そういう無力感を良いものみたいに思い込ん
で自分に言い聞かせていました
なんかそっちのほうが
謙虚に見える気がしたんです
でも
今日は胸を張って言いたいんですけど
僕はお母さんに優しい世界をつくってくることができました
今
こうしている今皆さんの目にはなぜか20
なぜか妊婦体験している24歳男性の姿が写ってますよね
それと同じような感じで世界のいろんな国の人のいろんな人たちの目に妊婦体験して
いるぼくの姿を写してくれました
僕なりのアイディアで世界を変えて来れたと思っています
そしてそれって多分すべての人にできるし
もうすでにしていることなのかもしれません
一人一人に
自分だけの冒険があると思います
どうかそれを大切にしてあげてください
その冒険は他の誰かではできないあなただけのものだと思うからです
僕の冒険のまとめをすると
リアグッズファーザー良いパパになってくださいと伝え続けてきました
でもその言葉がどんなことを指すのか僕実は全然わかんないです
良いパパーっていう言葉が指すものって
国によって宗教によって一つ一つのカップにとって違うものだと思います
女性と違って僕たち男性って体妊娠や出産を経験することができません
でもそのことに関して理解しようと努力することができます
僕たち弾車子供を産むことはできないけど一緒に子供を育てることができます
子供が未来をつくっていくじゃないですか
素敵な家庭を築いていくことってステキな未来を作っていくことにつながるんだと思い
ます
お母さんに優しい世界っていうのはすべての人に優しい世界ではないでしょうか
例えば
自分の奥さんのお腹が大きくなったときとか
自分のお子さんが何だろう名前機でこん畜生って思う時とか
お母さんの母の日プレゼントを買おうかなって思っている時やバンカーでもめんど
くさいなぁとか思う時とか
そんな時にどうか
妊婦体験ジャケットと一緒にせ回収した
学生の冒険の話を思い出してくれたら
そんなに嬉しいことはありません
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]